les russes ont déjà réussi à bloquer
certaines banques de craignait est-ce
qu'il serait capable aujourd'hui les
acteurs russes de tout bloquer et de
bloquer internet de bloquer électricité
en europe et partout je pense que oui on
a vu déjà en 2015 que la russie avait
fait sauter l'électricité pendant plus
de six heures pour une région
ukrainienne deux cent mille personnes
âgées on voit des attaques sur les
banques ça se passe en fait de façon à
ce qu'on en voit un flux massif de
données de connexion sur un serveur
façon de faire sauter c'est pour ça
qu'il ya des gens qui peuvent lui
retirer leur argent les banques ont peur
aussi derrière bien sûr je pense qu'il
faudrait réaliser aujourd'hui que une
guerre en 2022 ça joue sur deux fronts
il ya pour militaire vous en avait parlé
il ya pas d'interaction de troubles mais
il ya aussi le plan cyber et si on it
michaud je pense que malheureusement
loupé une lecture dax intéressantes sur
cette guerre et la russie aujourd'hui
ils sont capables d'aller très loin en
terme de
cyberguerre alors clairement c'est l'une
des trois meilleures nations au monde en
terme de cyberguerre aujourd'hui ils
peuvent faire énormément de choses que
ce soit de la surveillance sur les
réseaux sociaux que ce soit essayé
d'attaquer des caméras de sécurité il ya
énormément de choses qui sont faites en
fait de façon c'est une guerre
d'intelligence en fait de renseignement
et aujourd'hui tout passe par internet
alors sergei on va on va voir vous allez
nous expliquer aussi pour l'électricité
dans un instant parce que ça peut
concerner tous les français on peut se
retrouver sans électricité ce serait fou
serbie quand comment se fait-il pourquoi
les russes ils peuvent faire ça
aujourd'hui pas parce qu'on croit que
internet ça passe par les airs par des
satellites et en fait non ça passe pas
et 10% du trafic passe par les câbles
par en dessous comme la semaine parce
que en fait le câble c'est la fibre
optique donc ça va à la vitesse de la
lumière parce que quand ça passe par
parlait en fait on perd énormément
vitesse donc on a on a trouvé cette
solution là mais la faiblesse c'est
aussi la même ça veut dire que déjà
c'est d'or dans l'océan alors je vais
dans l'océan donc comment il parle quand
il pourrait couper l'électricité les
rues basses et les câbles c'est pas plus
gros que les tuyaux d'arrosage en est
donc après après il ya quand même bien
évidemment d'edu du métal là dedans mais
vous pouvez aussi à métaux enfin une psy
spécial éventuellement et bouc volley
volley coupé et surtout le truc c'est
que c'est des millions de kilomètres si
on ramasse tout au tout les câbles de
ses amis lyon 1,3 de kilomètres de
câbles ça veut dire trois fois à l'air
autour sur sur la lune ouais mais ici
coupe une fois ces morts ça dépend où
trouver d'accord mais ça ou pour le père
depuis les gens qui savent couple et
surtout ccc
soumaré c'est sérieux ça mine
on part demain d'autres graves mais je
suis pas dit non mais il coupe le truc
c'est finit plus non sérieusement c'est
il n'y a pas de faire est ce que tu
penses que c'est kiki c'est poutine
donné cette eau non mais n'importe quel
ennemi d'autres d'autres puissances
peuvent aussi le faire mais disons que
poutine on sait que c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui se dit vous m'emmerdez bah
je vais mourir vous emmerder et donc ça
c'est une faiblesse parce que ici
traités bien aussi que nos sociétés
maintenant sont tellement
interconnecté sûr que si on fait ça en
bas tout est régi par l'électricité et
par intérêt robin des bois à coeur
rabat des bois c'est quoi l'histoire
alors les câbles sous marins en plus de
représenter internet c'est aussi tout ce
qui est transactions bancaires
aujourd'hui à rennes le swift pas par
hasard donc ça sans rien ta strict sur
tout un tas d'industrie c'est aussi
peut-être pour ça que elon musk à
déployer le réseau de sardines en
ukraine il ya à peu près cinq jours pour
justement permettre aux ukrainiens et au
gouvernement d'avoir le pouvoir changer
de fusil d'épaulé en fait si un jour il
ya un problème donc cesser c'est
vraiment important fait de semer
aujourd'hui tout le monde pourrait le
faire mais la russie peut se dire j'en
vois quoi des hommes couper le câble et
non pas des hommes ça demande quand même
atteint
de l'équipement c'est assez conséquent
parce que des fois c'est très
profondément et donc il faut avoir quand
même des bathyscaphes des sous marins
qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 6000 mètres de
profondeur ils peuvent le faire ils
peuvent le faire ils ont les moyens de
le faire c'est qu'ils ont ils ont déjà
fait alors qu'ils ont déjà fait pour
l'ukraine ils ont déjà hâte en à
apprendre l'histoire en août 2000 21 on
a repéré un sous-marin
exactement qui est en train de se
reblesser fameux capteur il était sur un
navire espion qui est en train de
repérer ces fameux câble les hellènes ce
qui a demandé d'ailleurs elon musk un
plan b au cas où un maillage avec un
maillage satellitaire diriger une
sélection pour sa gay est ce que c'est
vrai que les sous-marins russes sont
d'ores et déjà base est positionné à des
endroits stratégiques pour pouvoir
rapidement coupé les câbles absolument
après neuf ans après absolument ils sont
déjà mais ça c'est une vraie réponse je
ne la donne pas non il m'a demandé jouit
donné tu ne manque de rien juste de
narnia
[Applaudissements]
je suis fan de ce gars voilà je les
adore
et donc c'est leur boulot c'est mon
boulot ça va mieux mais il faut
comprendre canal ils vont comprendre que
les militaires et ils passent leur temps
à à réfléchir comment on va emmerder les
gens d'en face c'est leur boulot et sont
payés pour ça
c'est en donne les moyens d'accord oui
batterie par rapport à ce qu'ils disent
et sur le réseau satellite du losc tout
à l'heure il admet ce qu'a fait un tweet
en disant de faire très attention avec
l'utilisation de son réseau starling
parce que justement il pourrait être
bombardé les stations de base pour être
bombardés par les russes alors déjà
les horizons ont fait sauter à un
satellite et surtout que ça a donné
plein de débris et dans l'espace pour
vous pour que vous compreniez ce atone à
30000 km heure l'heure ça veut dire que
un petit machin une aide de rien du tout
3 g ça devient un rack ou de deux tonnes
ça veut dire que ça peut détruire par
exemple la faction international de
spatiale et est donc et ils ont fait les
exercices ils ont fait évacuer même les
russes en bas ils ont fait sauter à tout
quand les russes étaient dans la station
donc ils ont mimé mais le propre
cosmonautes aux dons en danger alors non
on a peur également on le dit en europe
des sanctions au niveau de l'électricité
c'est quoi cette histoire pourrait être
privée d'électricité oui ça y est j'ai
une autre question ont dit les rues sont
prévus le double blackout donc black out
des télécommunications avec les
souverains qui couperait les câbles et
blackout de l'électricité de l'énergie
avec la conquête des centrales
nucléaires ukrainiennes ya peut-être
même d'autres menaces après donc si
c'est ça et les énergies plus
télécommunications l'europe et la france
sont dans le noir complet non fournis
dont les centrales c'est l'ukraine oui
parce que c'est les centrales l'ukraine
possède six centrales il ya le
tchernobyl qui est arrêté ils ont cinq
centrales ils ont quinze réacteurs plus
de réacteurs de recherche et donc d'en
camp quand les militaires de notre côté
ils ont des pleurs ils passent leur
temps à regarder prenons l'ukraine qui
est sont les points
avant de l'avic donc les routes des
communications les téléphones les
centrales et mon général droz d'offres
qui dirigeait la direction s des
illégaux et nous disait avec 100 tonnes
en une semaine je vous bloque l'europe
ah ouais avec son homme parce que il
suffit d'envoyer des duos avec de
l'explosif et on peut bloquer en une
semaine je vous dirai pas comment parce
que sinon il ya des gens actuellement
qui regardent et guy sûrs y compris chez
nous peut-être non non non
bravant des bois sur l'électricité
c'était c'est possible aussi parce que
ça nous fait on se dit on va se
retrouver dans le noir l'europe l'europe
peut être touchés donc puisque vous le
dites avec 100 tonnes par an aux les
pentes d'électricité c'est ce qu'on
appelle un olivier c'est un organisme
d'importance vitale en france et l'inde
6 qui s'occupe de faire en sorte que
tout se passe bien par rapport à ça mais
bien sûr en fait c'est tout ce dont on
prend pour acquis mais qui est
essentielle à la bonne survie d'un pays
que le traitement des eaux l'énergie
l'électricité c'est sans faite aux
jeunes et route se poser problème les
routes également et tout ça
malheureusement s'est connecté à
internet et du coup il faut faire
attention parce que la cyber guerre se
joue sur scène elle se joue pas sur
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on jouait
encore sur le syndrome de la peur parce
que là ce qu'on est en train d'expliquer
là si jamais ils pensaient disposer ces
dispositions là ça voudra dire que ça
allait rentrer en troisième guerre
mondiale parce qu'il s'attaque à
l'europe on a commencé à faire peur aux
gens on allait recevoir des bombes
atomiques sur la tronche bon après on
nous a dit c'était cette pluie si vous
regardez un peu les infos les états unis
qui disait attention est en train de
bombarder une centrale nucléaire
l'autorité
à bâtiment juste à côté il n'a pas
bombardé les réacteurs les sirènes là on
est en train de nous dire on va perdre
un téléphone on a pu voir l'existence
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on continue de
faire ses montées peur et s'est montée
de pression en fait sur la shoah pas du
tout c'est juste que excusez moi oui ça
peut arriver à respecter
vous n'êtes pas moi je prends pour vous
n'avez pas confiance numérique vous
réalisez parce que vous êtes autonome
vous êtes un pion sur l'échiquier
england et vous réalisez pas en fait que
moi je pense que le genre est bien qu'il
le fasse ou pas ce que je fais je prends
pas grave je dis pas du mal à me sens de
ce qui se passe comme ça je vais pas
tout vous n'avez pas le faire
analyser ce qu'il ne fera pas bac s
qu'ils ont c'est
lorsque olive je pense que j'ai un gros
niveau longueur
j'ai fait les études avec ce gars là
ouais ouais voilà on voyait à moscou
pour faire ses études pour devenir
espion il a fait une année d'études et
chez nous dans le service d'espionnage
qu'on a écrit mes généraux ont écrit ce
mec est dangereux pour lui et pour le
service on n'en veut pas le kgb l'a
écrit et la renvoyer à leningrad était
en train de le défendre en disant il est
responsable il faut le mettre à la table
de négociations mais il est ce que je
peux te poser juste une question et
messiaen quel serait l'intérêt pour
vladimir poutine aujourd'hui dans les
cas il vous en guerre avec l'europe et
avec les états au cas mais il le fait en
fous et les faux l'europe c'est son
client sans fournir de montant ni la saq
l'europe aucune sanction aucun mais il
est illettré siona irait rationnelle aux
ukrainiens je regarde toujours à qui
profite le jeu va dire je n'y en a
presque plus et ne pas dire après
bah moi très honnêtement aujourd'hui je
pense que indirectement le crime profite
très quand même fortement à l'europe et
surtout aux états unis pour qu'ils
puissent vendre leur pétrole et le gaz
je pense que les dispositions qui sont
prises aujourd'hui en train d'écraser je
ne dis pas que ce qui fait c'est bien
mais on est quand même en train
d'essayer d'écraser la deuxième
puissance mondiale en disant non
j'en ai adoré me sanson
l'atrazine chez les japonais peut-être
première avec huawei et chinois les
américains les chinois donc ils sont
les poutine au niveau économique il
arrive c'est 6 c'est une punaise mais
avec un énorme territoire mais c'est une
punaise au niveau militaire ses trois
passions ses 3 % le week end est
essentiel c'est bien ce que vous êtes en
train d abord melix et rien que c'est
une punaise mais sais tu n'es pas
capable
mais c'est sûr ça ils te menace avec
nucléaire parce que c'est une prothèse
alors rappelez vous vouliez dire un truc
non j'allais dire que vous loupez vous
voyez pas le fait on fait le conflit il
est aussi sur le fond sur le plan cyber
genius peut pas retirer leur argent des
banques ça fait c on voit pourquoi
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui l'ukraine accepte
les donations aux cryptes ont mené ils
ont reçu 17 millions d'euros en l'espace
d'une semaine en cryptant menaces parce
qu'ils n'ont pas confiance dans les
banques ça moi je dis pas que ça peut
pas exister ce que tu dis ça je dis je
dis simplement que ça engagerait des
normes chose derrière et je pense qu'on
essaye d'influer sur la peur encore un
maximum quelque chose et moi c'est moi
je pense que ça va
continuer mais on en reparlera dans
quelques semaines avait raison
et sergei j'ai combien ça prendrait le
temps aux russes pour
voile a coupé l'électricité dans toute
l'europe et couper internet
quelques jours d'accord si c'était déjà
en cours on le saurait non ça on saurait
peut-être même déjà travaillé la chose
déjà bien longtemps mais on a envie de
juste les gens qui sont là bas les
journalistes tout ça n'utilisez pas
télégramme qui est connecté avec pavel
du rove qu'un millier des russes
utilisez plutôt signal pensé à utiliser
des logiciels
chiffré de bout en bout signalez mieux
que télégramme aujourd'hui si vous êtes
en ukraine faites attention parce que ce
que dit la personne à ma gauche je suis
désolé mais je suis je suis abattu et en
fait par un niveau de conscience
numerama c'est fait mais ça fait quatre
fois que je te répète je te dis que ça
peut exister mais que je pense qu'il le
fera pas c'est ce que je te
reviendra dans quelques jours et on
verra qui avait la vue voilée assise
toute l'électricité c'est pour certaines
ce qui vous connaît pas la crise vous
êtes on en a eu plein de poulets par là
qui a
au niveau livre d'accord parce qu'il dit
là je ne crois pas sauf que l'enjeu
c'est la troisième guerre mondiale vous
pensez qu'il va le faire mais ça ça oui
à la barre ce qui va couper internet je
vous demande m'a dit vrai que dans les
plans d'envahissement de l'ukraine il ya
une bombe tactiques nucléaires qui va
sauter je les dis sur un plateau judy
l'année de la semaine dernière on m'a
rigolé au nez
trois jours après poutine a dit je
m'aime et se met mes forces nucléaires
en en alerte mais il était déjà en
alerte ses forces à nourrir quand on
voit nos guerres c'est fort non et si
les forces de dissuasion était forcément
en à l'hermine ans et c'était vraiment
une alerte ça c'est connu non c'est pas
l'économie mais ben non c'est pas les
couilles rtg lors de dissuasion en fait
tu les mets forcément en place abbatiale
mais non c'est pas
du tout
c'est vêtue en ce même lieu ici que là
où il a raison